armstrong et aldrin il y a vingt ans sur
la lune ça vous savez sûrement mais
tintin sur la lune
rappelez vous c'était il ya quarante ans
et à cette occasion une fusée bien
curieuse s'est envolé tout à l'heure de
la base de kourou en guyane il s'agit en
fait de la réplique exacte de la célèbre
fusée de on a marché sur la lune
une façon de fêter les 40 ans de cet
album et les 60 ans de tintin le
pionnier puisque c'est lui qui
finalement est le premier à avoir marché
sur la lune
nathalie darrigrand à -4 3 2 à 1
il a fallu et les techniciens du centre
spatial dont qu'on fasse de lyon et vu
d'effectivement ils ont trouvé une
remède qui est d'ailleurs ce prêt est en
fait serait plus exact sinon ça ne sera
plus la fusée de l'accusé de tapin elle
est absolument identique à celle que
l'on voit dans les aventures de
printemps
il armstrong le premier homme à avoir
marché sur la lune tous les
tintinophiles vous diront le contraire
19 ans avant la nasa notre reporter
avait déjà transformé le rêve en réalité
aussi et pour en finir avec ces rumeurs
tinta était aujourd'hui à kourou sa
fusée haut de deux mètres cinquante est
partie au premier compte à rebours pour
un vol historique de 15 secondes
atteignant la remarquable altitude de
800 m une histoire digne de ses héros et
d'un cadeau d'anniversaire teinte par le
saviez vous a 60 ans cette année
le sport hippique va venir